Hey, Vsauce. Michael here, next to a giant bird,
which can only mean one thing.
I'm in London, where even the pillows
say "God save the Queen." It's a cushion, Michael.
Alright, look.
I've got a bird trying to tell me what to say.
That's right, in England
this is a bird and this is a bird.
Of course, I call her Hazel.
But I've got a piece of knowledge for you,
Hazel. It's a new word and the word is DONG.
DONG.
Is that
something you eat?
No. It's things you do online now guys.
Iambebeast recommended Musicovery,
an awesome site with a mood pad.
Mouse over the pad to choose you current or
desired mood
and it immediately changes.
You can even focus it on a decade or genre
within your mood. But if you want
complete control, upload your own favorite
song to Pixel White,
like you Ulication. The game lasts as
long as the song you upload
and the songs' equalizer bars become the
plane space.
Dizquier91 brought up a list of sites,
where you can waste time like a professional.
While I was there,
I found Nooooooooooooooo.com.
When something terrible happens,
go there and push the button.
I also discovered ooooiiii.com.
The title makes more sense after you go
there. But if you want TheCasalex's
computerception,
play a game where you're on a computer.
Or Coachhere recommends a game with state of the art
ASCII graphics. You're a Rafflecopter
dropping WTF bombs
on guys wearing roller skates.
Too fancy?
Well, play this even simpler game programmed to
happen inside your URL bar.
Use the arrow keys to move the "O" to
lasso A's
and press the spacebar to kill as many
as possible in 30 seconds.
PointlessSites is another good
collection of places. While I was there
I found one billion mazes, a site that literally
has 1,000,000,000 mazes. If you solved
one maze every single second,
it would take you more than 31 years to
finish them all.
Speaking of long times, here's a YouTube
video of a guy counting to 100
thousand and yeah, that says 74 hours.
41, 42, 43.
44, 45.
But to feel really sad, play Platform
and learn a life lesson.
Videos, do you want more?
Well, this one is a really sweet playlist
containing the first
hour of MTV as it originally aired with
the original commercials. And lately I've
been working with Greg from Dr. Coolsex
and getting into his WTF series.
Each week
we learn a little bit more about what
happened or what's happen...
...ing. You be the judge. And if you're in
London, I hope to see you at Summer in the
City tomorrow.
And as always,
thanks for watching.